hello and welcome to Coffee House shots
of Spectators daily and sometimes more
than daily politics podcast I'm Katie
balls and I'm joined by James Forsyth
so James we now have a new Tory leader
not yet prime minister
yep so the king is returning to London
but apparently Liz Tross wants to do a
cabinet tomorrow and I think there is
some uncertainty about who will do pmqs
on Wednesday uh and it's also worth
remembering I think that from the point
of view of the Machinery of government
no one was quite sure even at kind of 1
30 today whether this contest was going
to Friday or whether it was going to
wrap up today and it ended up wrapping
up today because Penny Warden didn't get
100 nominations she needed on the ballot
to get on the ballot paper
um all right so I think we now are in
this kind of slightly older interregnum
period where Richard sunac is leader of
a conservative party but not yet prime
minister
um and I think there are a few you know
interesting developments so far I mean
the first thing uh is uh and I should
say that I've known I know if she's
doing it for years um the first thing
I'm gonna say is I thought it was
striking that there was no other
candidate on the ballot I I think that
you know given the number of Undeclared
conservative MPS it was entirely
possible there might have been another
candidate on the ballot I think that is
an interesting sign of of party unity
and and seeing Patty Morgan got quite
close yeah I mean she was just she was
pushing him to the very end it seems
yeah when when that announcement I was
quite struck but um which said you know
payment was obviously you know the party
wants to press on it it didn't come
across as [ __ ] had a moment of
no right it was more as though MP's had
forced her into a situation where she
couldn't get on there no no I wrote the
statement two times so I couldn't quite
first work out whether she had whether
she got the message and decided not to
to run or not
and then I think but I think there is a
you know look it is day one and things
would be very bad if there was not a
kind of feeling of Unity on day one no
um no but I think there was a and I
think it is interesting
um one soon act supporting MP said to me
that you know what they were encouraged
by was how many of Boris Johnson's
supporters have publicly declared for
Russia's United making the point but
they didn't need to do that they could
have sat on their hands and just said oh
whatever I'm not doing anything else
um and so I think that that is a kind of
interesting sign I think now the
challenge is the Tory party has been so
Riven by factionalism and tensions and
all this Bridges you don't need to show
that he is creating an internal
coalition
uh and here's the show in his cabinet
choices that you know he is going to
pick uh people from all the wings of the
party or and you know and all the people
with all the and people of talent from
right across the party I mean one of the
things that causes trust so many
problems when she got into trouble was
that you know the the famous line to
Grant chaps that you know yes you're
very good and competent but you didn't
support me so there's no room at the end
uh and I think he has got to break with
that and and I thought it was very
telling that in the one brief statement
we've had from him on camera since he
became uh Tory leader you know he went
out of his way to pay tribute to Liz
truss's um Grace uh and I mean that
that's clearly him trying to say look
let's come together let's unite and that
you know and that he is not he's not
going to criticize his predecessors do
you think Rishi c network goes so far as
to offer Liz trust a job in his cabinet
I think there is always an interesting
question about whether former Prime
Ministers wish to come back and of in
cabinets but they can be offered it and
then no I I think I think that look I
personally think that if you're trying
to knit things together it is a sensible
unifying gesture if people want to do it
I think it's quite some time since I
think Alexa was Hume is the last former
prime minister to return to Cabinet in
another role but no but look I think you
I think you have to
you if you want to talk about Unity you
have to show that you are taking big
steps to try and bring people together
um now you mentioned Richard's public
statement before we got to that he also
addressed Tory MPS in private and
meeting the 22 committee and I was still
outside lots of cheers and banging on
desks so that I as you say I think on
day one it would be more you know a very
bad sign for British unit that wasn't
happening that a great sign for his you
know prosperity and so forth um that it
is
um but you know a mix of attendees now
his message and similar to this you know
he began by saying Boris Liz Penny and
paying tribute so again a big effort to
reach across and effectively told MPS
that they had a choice unite or die and
pitched as
um the final chance really to uh get
this government back together and I
think when what I was told by MPS was
when he was laying out
um well he thought you know the the two
big challenges were the first was to
restore fiscal competence credibility
and the second was to actually give you
know restore faith in the Tory party
give people a reason to think they
should Vote for This government that is
doing things for them
by his priorities because a lot of
people have been I think watching this
and thought we haven't heard from this
whole process yes it's a very short
process and but that was a private
audience and then you had the public
address not looking in the right camera
and but it was pretty short so when we
came over from Russia now I mean I
presume when he actually enters Downing
Street I think there is no I mean I mean
I think it is unclear to me whether that
is uh tomorrow or later in the week
um I I think the big I mean there's
there's there is a very funny thing
about this process you're you're clearly
right to say that this process has been
kind of largely conducted in private
yeah yeah I think to be fair to him and
maybe I would say this wouldn't I you
know he did do the Andrew into in the
summer but Nick Robinson is for you in
the summer and the nature of his contest
it means that you've you know it has
never got to the stage where there was I
mean there was a plan for a TV debate
between the last two candidates that
have gone to the membership but I do
think that one of the things you have to
do is to say to the public is to make
the public feel that you know you are
there prime minister too uh and I mean
that that is one of the clearly one of
the challenges this week I think it's I
think you know if you look at his launch
statement one of the things he's trying
to say is that he wants to deliver on
the promise of a 2019 Manifesto and I
mean that emphasis on the 2019 Manifesto
it is a bit of a contrast to listro and
it's worth remembering that the the
whole fracking vote on the Wednesday
that caused her if it feels like ancient
history now which causes so much trouble
with the debate about what was it a
confidence vote was it not a confidence
vote I think a lot of the problem there
was that some of the Tory Rebels were
like hang on a second you're putting me
on a three-line whip to vote against a
Manifesto commitment which was to
maintain the morator which was to keep a
moratorium on fracking and so I think
that you know I think that you going
back to the 2019 Manifesto could serve a
unifying purpose and one of the
difficulties though is obviously events
have moved on since 2019 Manifesto
you've had covid you've had the Russian
invasion of Ukraine and so yeah there is
a question as to whether everything in
the 2019 Manifesto is deliverable in the
current circumstances given everything
that is happening
but I think that you know I mean one of
the I think one of the causes about
smash up that Wednesday was people felt
that they were being free line whipped
against a Manifesto commitment now let's
look ahead we don't have exact timings
But ultimately Rishi neck needs to meet
the king
uh then he will enter 10 Downing Street
and then do we expect recently then
former government uh in terms of do you
think he'll do a drastic don't worry
shuffles the right word in this case a
drastic Shaker for the front bench team
or not because it feels to me as though
the team he probably would have said
that if it won the first leadership
contest would look a bit different to
the one he assembles now in a sense he's
walking to a much more fragile situation
with more questions about his mandate
and obviously there's a need to reach
across yeah and I also think there is
that there is a different point which is
you know
it is remarkable when you read some of
these pieces you know people talk about
a x you know the fifth Secretary of
State for this or something this year
right but that there is clearly problems
with that and you cannot just keep
rotating ministers at this pace without
losing something so I mean there is
clearly a case for
um for not for you know for starting
with the current list rather than
starting from a blank sheet of paper
um so
any what do you think is going to happen
when it comes to Chancellor because both
Penny modern and Boris Johnson suggested
they're keep Jeremy Hunt in place Jeremy
Hunt endorsed Richard not once but twice
he also backed him over the summer so of
all the people who really you know
probably should give them a good job of
a Boris Johnson Penny model number she's
like you think it'd be Richie's sooner
carries Jeremy Hunt the most but he's
also a former Chancellor he might have
his own views do you think there is a
reason he didn't give that commitment to
keep Jeremy Hunt I think that you know I
think it's quite telling that in the
campaign I don't think he said you know
and he didn't he didn't say anyone who's
going to do XY was their job and I also
think he probably
one of the reasons I think for for Penny
Morton's I think what she was trying to
say was you know she's never been a
treasury Minister
um I mean what she was trying to say
during the campaign was look you know
there will be someone there to reassure
the markets and I think Boris Johnson
was also you know uh you know trying to
do the same thing to say look don't
don't think the markets are going to
take fright I mean returning to number
10 because the chancellor that will will
will stay there as a sign of continuity
and stability
um and so I think I think we wait to see
on that question I mean there is a there
is a interesting question about whether
you go ahead with this Halloween fiscal
statement
um I mean I thought previously I thought
that was an impossibility because you
know the nature of when these measures
need to go to the OVR means that you
know the new prime minister wouldn't
have any time at all to have us to to
look at them and they will Define the
rest of his Parliament you know now the
prime minister is going to get in a few
days earlier I don't know how much you
know that that you could argue with that
changes in calculations but I personally
think that one of the things we need
that one of the child
is British politics has been moving on
kind of fast forward for
um uh for essentially since 2014 I mean
I think it is it it is hard to remember
a boring period in British politics in
the last eight years and I think calming
everything down slowing things down
saying look there's a budget on November
23rd you know let's work towards that
rather than going at this this pace you
know I think it's worth remembering that
you know people talk about Breakneck
speed Breakneck speed is not necessarily
a good thing it means that you might
break your neck
um and and so I think there is a case
for slowing down calming things uh being
a sensible approach
so I suppose just finally I mean it
might work just working out what are the
biggest challenges or dangers versus
unit coming up the track it's been
interesting I thought how the European
research group didn't endorse a
candidate which some readers good news
for Richie sunax some readers good news
for petty Morton obviously it wasn't
that good news anymore didn't I'm giving
she didn't make the cut
um but effectively we were saying
they're gonna hold whoever you know
because prime minister count on this uh
suggesting if the protocol doesn't you
know if a compromise well if the bill
doesn't I'll go through Parliament it
raises questions about a compromise and
what British student could get through
and what else do you think of the
potential Flashpoint so I think there
are a whole slew of challenges spending
um yeah so I I think one of the ones I
would say is one of the biggest
challenges I think for the Tory party
which hasn't been discussed in this
contest wasn't actually much discussed
in the summer either is the NHS is
already under pressure in the way that
you would expect it to be under pressure
in January or February I mean the
biggest political risk of its Allure is
is you know the NHS having a very bad
winter and people saying well hang on a
second what you know that when Portland
Steve Barkley was was house actually
um in the summer you know that one so
you've had 12 years to sort this out why
isn't this fixed and that was obviously
slightly unfair to him since he only
just become Health secretary but that
problem secondly there is the economic
problem which is you know look the
markets have reacted positively to
riches United winning the pound is up
guilt yields are down
um but you know that there is still this
very large hole in the public finances
which I think at the last OVR estimate
was like 72 billion pounds that that is
not going to be easy to fix then as you
rightly say there is the
um the political challenge of a deeply
divided tour party you know I I mean
it's always people react in one of two
ways to these polls showing them more
than 30 plus points behind they either
will say uh oh well you know we might as
well all go back to fighting each other
because it's all done or and I think the
signs are but this is where they're
going or they will realize that this is
an existential moment for the party and
they've got to pull together or it's not
you know or they could be facing kind of
proper Wipeout
then there's obviously and it tells you
something about a number of crises we've
only just got to this then there is a
situation the fact there is a war in
Europe you have you know the defense
Ministers of uh the UK France and the
U.S issuing joint statements about the
warning Russia against the use of a
dirty bomb in Ukraine I think that that
again is a reminder of how serious those
are and as you say you know this is you
we're at a time when we're when when the
public finances are saying that there
needs to be a period of fiscal
consolidation there are also increasing
and understandable demands for for an
uplift in defense spending now
there is already an uplift in defense
spending but you know I think Ben
Wallace the defense actually has been
pretty vocal but he would like more
sooner
um so that is obviously another
challenge and we haven't even got on to
the challenges around the union the fact
we're still waiting for the Supreme
Court uh the case verdict on the the
Scottish government's desire to hold a
to hold a referendum on Independence
which they said would be non-binding so
look the the challenges facing this
government would be immense even if its
government was starting a five-year term
and was ahead in the polls it's got two
years left or so until the next election
and it starts with the Tory party 30
points behind so this is about as
difficult as it can get and on that
cheery note for Rishi sunak in case he
is watching uh we will end that there
thank you James and thank you for
watching